what's the deal with airplane peanuts
but virgin power is so strong bro
oh dude that's crazy oh a uh somebody
parked a volkswagen rabbit on this guy's
leg one time outside of our schoolhouse
and i saw a virgin [ __ ] lift it right
off his leg wild
yo and this was in [ __ ] who knows
what it was every scene is from like the
movie powder
every scene it's amazing what are you
talking about every scene if you're live
stories like that i've never seen a
virgin pick up a car
yeah they pick up ak-47s now that's the
problem
virgins now are picking up ar-15s
hopefully they start picking up cars
again that would be nice
they need to grab some [ __ ] then bruh i
agree with you because they're shutting
down all the [ __ ] bruh that's who's
doing it
that's right yes i will take a
controversial stance
because i believe epstein is a pedophile
okay you heard it here
okay and you think geez lane was his
little his uh
his his runner yeah i think that's
pretty well established i think miss
maxwell was involved in some alert and
inappropriate activities
but as trump would say i wish her well
yeah because that's the way rich people
talk
rich people every now and then rich
people just
become rich and they forget that they
have a job he forgot he was the
president yeah he was i had a golf tee
on mar-a-lago in his mind and he he said
what he would have said
to some ceo that was next to me yeah i
was sure well
when you're under when you're under the
balls and you're sleeping in some hair
or
whatever you keep your head out of the
balls that's a real moment
that's a real moment in your life like
one of those moments for me i was santa
claus in like harlem
and i was getting [ __ ] on all day by
like four-year-old kids
and you can say black kids yeah they
were there well some of them are
with dominican but they were just
roasting me just
shamelessly be none of them were happy
to see santa these are hardened little
kids they're like [ __ ] you you fat [ __ ]
i'm like i'm santa you know yeah and i
would jing the jingle the bell and then
every now and then some drunk would like
dance with me and i was like this is a
rough
i hope comedy works out you know so that
had to be the ball pit moment when your
head's out of the balls you're like
god i hope this works out i did cocaine
with a substitute
and that's all that's as far as i got
which is how old are you
i was maybe 18 maybe like the year i
graduated high school
we were doing coke with uh one of our
substitutes and was he a homosexual or
she no it was a chat
a woman yeah she was just um subs of the
end dude what class
she was an english sub so she was an
idiot yeah
so she wasn't smart she was probably
trying to go out and sniff some coke and
you know [ __ ] her way into the lower
middle class she's [ __ ] her way into a
little
levitt house in long island good woman
oh my god bro you got to play santa more
often dude
i would love to watch the small black
kids attack they just roasted me they
were brutal uh here's a guy obviously
he's looking to date
this guy looks like he's in trouble it
kind of looks like he didn't answer a
contact racing call
he's infected 38 people hey uh mr dillon
uh
huge fan mr vaughn long time
long time listener watcher first time
caller and communicator pardon my back
mullet
i don't have a top mullet but i got a
little back hair i'm gonna let that heat
go anyway i got a
crazy question from mr dylan what do you
think about the assassin
killing himself that shot the judge's
son
this just lane maxwell shit's getting a
little [ __ ] yeah it's real creepy
yeah so let's get into that first let's
just establish that
epstein you believe epstein was a
pedophile
i'm just saying let's just establish
some great what are you working for
hold on what
do you ever think do you ever meet women
that are
close on a like there's almost like a
because sometimes i almost wonder if at
a certain point that gay and straight
will almost be primitive
descriptions like i know some of there's
a lot of force stuff and like
you know and people like in this place
now where they don't know or they
you know and people are just i think sex
will be primitive i think people are on
so many ssris they can't even come and
i mean you can't get dicks hard i mean
just crazy you look at a lot of these
relationships you're like
there's no sex happening these people
just hold each other's hands they softly
cry
they tweet about racism uh they adopt a
dog together
uh but you you really sexual a lot of
these relationships are
you're like a lot of this is probably
just people that have
massive anxiety laying next to each
other having multiple panic attacks
and then someone's strong enough to go
make a cup of
like non-caffeinated tea but if you ever
yeah um during a
tough panic attack but it's almost not
to move yeah
it's not the move well i mean i try
tweet out things hoping to you know
you know to get something and no one
cares yeah that's okay you ever rile
anyone up
sometimes people people are carrying
more now though i think people your
career is getting bigger
it's been better now last six months
yeah you know i had to really turn it up
you know say megan mccain [ __ ] her dad
i had to take it to the next level oh
yeah
yeah and then people were like oh okay
we'll listen to this incest will get
people to move
yeah i had to say she had sex with her
father's corpse and then people like
oh okay but here's the thing about
incest dude everybody's like ah
no no right yeah but what i'm thinking
about is
um dude back in the day you didn't have
the only people who lived around you
were kind of family or somebody that was
you know yeah close and you didn't have
everyone didn't have a bicycle or
like if you had a bicycle then yeah
maybe you'd [ __ ] somebody that wasn't
distantly related to you yeah but if you
didn't
you could only have sex with as far as
you could walk or as far as you could
yeah you know so you would people would
have sex more locally yeah you didn't
have a choice i think that still goes on
i think that's still probably happening
oh yeah there's some areas and stuff you
go and you're like oh yes
i think people are using that exact
rationale too when they're in court
they're like listen i i have sex as far
as i walk
and then there's a judge going okay
sounds great yeah yeah
i hate i hated myself that like looking
back now looking back now
at the time i was like this is dope yeah
i'm a youtube star
yeah and now i'm just like [ __ ] you just
acting out i don't yeah i think so i
think i was just lashing i was i was
pissed that everyone hated me
yeah you're doing the crazy prank yeah
have you ever done one of those where
you regretted it like
a crazy prank well obviously the one
that we all know about the one in the
forest
yeah right that one which i didn't even
think was offensive i was like whatever
i didn't know that i don't you don't
strike me as a person who found it
offensive no
i i mean me and my friends played with
dead people alive people
people who you know
why did you just couldn't get any we
couldn't monetize it because we were
we were from the generation that can't
monetize
the sociopathy but i wish we no but that
wasn't that wasn't
but have you ever done something where
you're like oh i shouldn't uh
yeah man i poured gasoline on my brother
uh i tried to pour gasoline on my
brother he ran away and i slipped in it
and almost broke my shoulder yeah
dude my boy todd one time at halloween
drank a [ __ ] half gallon of gasoline
dude and no joke we never [ __ ] saw
him again
yeah and guess what never probably fine
oh i think he's fine but i think he's
never going to be fully fine
right now oh speaking of asians bro we
got a [ __ ] asian right here let's
hear this beautiful viet
hey what's up guys so my question is for
both you guys so
if you guys have the chance to have an
interview or a podcast with
anyone dead or alive who would that be
[ __ ] man that question always sucks i
feel like
yeah no offense man sorry i shouldn't
have said that
it's a basic [ __ ] question it's just
yeah it's a very basic [ __ ]
oh we got a version right here let's
hear this young woman this is the
furthest thing from
a basic [ __ ] question what's up theo
this question's for all three of you
guys
you can't leave the room until you form
a human centipede what's the order going
to be
oh andrew god [ __ ] what are
these are our fans yeah these are people
coming in from
8-chan it's 4chan now dude right they
took four away
oh you're eating cleanest so i would
probably say you up top yeah
tight tight you're up front i got to go
in the back because i have the least
amount of going on
in my career yesterday the caboose dude
yeah i have the least amount going on my
manager would be like
you're lucky to be there you eat who's
ever asked
they tell you to eat don't start any
problems
you don't say you don't eat in the ass
bro you're just being hair as a
receptacle it's a human centipede right
but don't get sexual we're there to
[ __ ] survive
you know what i'm trying to get out of
the room it's like an escape room this
guy obviously works at the mall
the middle this guy works at the mall
where do you think he even come up with
the question at the mall all day
smelling churros thinking about what to
ask
the middle person dies quick though theo
i think because but i'll sacrifice
myself just to get out of the [ __ ]
situation did you see that movie i never
saw that movie oh because they're
they're why because they're wait one one
of them dies quick
just like you know like biology oh
interesting
yeah yeah you get
i saw the movie did you i didn't see
them i see it
is it brutal great flick i want to watch
let's i want to watch it
not now but like tonight go to our own
respective
places back to our neutral corners i'm
not saying let's just watch a movie for
two hours right back to our neutral
corners
yeah wow
you